well we love a good Leonardo DiCaprio
sighting
on Saturday Leo hit the can red carpet
with Robert De Niro and Martin Scorsese
for the world premiere of their new film
killers of the flower moon what Marty
does so incredibly well is is able to
expose the the humanity of of even some
of the most Twisted Sinister characters
you could ever imagine can you find the
wolves in this picture the American true
crime drama out October 20th is about
the reign of terror a series of brutal
murders of the Osage tribe in 1920s
Oklahoma
it's been 37 years since Scorsese had a
film he directed at the festival and it
did not disappoint more than 2500 people
gave it a nine minute standing ovation
for us it was really very nice the
carpet was also date night for De Niro
and his martial arts instructor
girlfriend Tiffany Chen who just
welcomed the 79 year old star's seventh
child Leo's BFF Toby Maguire showed his
support along with Kate Blanchett who
looked Glam in a custom black and white
Louis Vuitton dress with her 21 year old
son dashel by her side
other star sightings Leo's fling Gigi
Hadid made a stunning entrance
recreating her sister Bella's look at
the premiere of Jude Law's new movie
Firebrand Sydney Sweeney left her hotel
arm and arm with fiance Jonathan devino
look close and you'll catch a glimpse of
that on-again off-again engagement ring
meanwhile Michelle yeoh showed off three
different looks in can but our favorite
is definitely this one there's the Oscar
winner on top of a chair getting down
with Oscar winner Brie Larson
[Music]